success is within someone's own
well-being it's having a passion toward
something is successful
I'm Adam Vanunu I'm 28 years old and I'm
the founder and creative director of
common citizen I was 23 years old when I
decided to start cutting citizen I got
interested in fashion watching my father
built a factory in Los Angeles and I
came up with the idea to really just
bring modern basics into what we were
doing the manufacturing facility was
very heavily focused on denim and
creating a novelty t-shirts was a way to
add on another category of what we were
producing we like to focus on showing
the saturation of colors and the dyes
and the treatments and all of that goes
back to what we do in-house as a factory
and where the business really all
originated from
[Music]
you know we have many celebrities
running the brand it goes from you know
your top models where it's Romi GG or
you know Kendall it's all your top
models to athletes and it shows the
sense of community who and what the
brand stands for my father passed away I
was 19 years old and with that comes
many many responsibilities you know one
being the oldest in the family and
having to completely take over a factory
with about 300 employees there's very
difficult going into it there's so many
different levels of what we do as a
business servicing customers and clients
to understanding how to manufacture and
keep the product relevant to what's
happening and innovative but we have a
great team these are people or my family
they've been there for 30 plus years and
then we're guiding them through out the
way
[Music]
you know being a bass and 19 years old
it's very hard to gain the respect from
many people it's really understanding
each person as an individual respecting
them but also showing them that you work
hard and that you show up every day you
just really have had that drive in you
you know these days social media the way
people are interacting with one another
is completely global and it brings the
world to a very small space and having
communities all around the world just
understand what we're doing
as a band it just unifies us all
[Music]
you